hector guards are right there too the
national border patrol council vice
president hector i imagine it's going to
get a lot tougher for your men and women
now
well it's it's good it's very important
to note that there's two different
categories of illegal aliens that come
across the border illegally right uh one
of them the the people that are seeking
asylum those are the people that are
going to be emboldened to come across uh
because now we're going to be seeing the
catch-and-release program on steroids
and the other categories those people
are trying to get away uh what happens
is that our agents will be now
processing more than ever before and all
these criminal illegal aliens and all
these drug smugglers will be scot-free
and aliens will continue to die in the
back of 18 wheelers and illegal aids
will continue to die in vehicle pursuits
and the worst part of this is that our
american citizens our communities are
being impacted by by these crimes and
unfortunately this at the end of the
migrant protection protocols is just
going to bolt into the the by the
administration and it's going to
encourage for legal immigration to
continue from all over the world so
hector let me ask you a little bit about
the processing here if they don't know
have to remain in mexico and presume
that means they they're here and they're
processed and we're not even including
the godaways who as the name implies get
away and and they avoid all of that uh
it could take years to do that right and
and then what
so first of all the migrant protection
protocols applies for those people that
are seeking asylum right uh the
remaining mexico policy for those people
that seek asylum instead of waiting in
the u.s and and using u.s resources that
would in turn wait in mexico but now
that the supreme court has shut down the
migrant protection protocols that means
that we're going to be having more and
more people seeking asylum people that
usually do not qualify for asylum
because these are economic uh migrants
what that intrigue is gonna is gonna is
gonna cause is that now our agents are
gonna be uh have to be processing more
women and children and we're going to
have absolutely no time no staff no
equipment to go after the real uh
criminal aliens that have those serious
criminal records for either serving
criminal time uh in jail here in the
united states or jail in their home
countries unfortunately this is very
very bad for the united states we
respect the court's opinion and the
ruling but this is very bad for us and
the border communities and for the
entire nation and that's just a small
fraction those who are you know seeking
the security here in the united states
uh but that's a multi-year process going
through that and there's no guarantee
they end up showing up when they have to
show up right
yeah most of these people that actually
uh get to remain in the united states
awaiting their assigned policies their
asylum hearings they don't get granted
that those hearings and what ends up
happening is that they just disappear
into the united states they end up
getting more more roots in the u.s and
they will never be deported especially
under a vital administration that has
has pretty much decriminalized illegal
immigration if you're here no matter
what you're doing in the u.s that long
you're establishing roots in the u.s
to your point hector thank you very much
keep us posted my friend good luck
through this hector guards of the
national border patrol hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now